ja
nato-außenminister und der eu
außenminister wir müssen eu und die nato
außenminister verurteilen aufs schärfste
den brutalen angriff russlands auf die
ukraine das ist der schlimmste angriff
trägt seit jahrzehnten
krankenhäuser schulen
wohnhäuser werden erbarmungslos
beschossen
letzte nacht erfolgte auch ein angriff
auf ein kernkraftwerk und es bereits
jetzt viele zivilisten verwundet oder
gestorben und europäische soldat muss je
länger der krieg dauert desto mehr tote
desto mehr leid und leiden desto mehr
verstörung
russland bringt leider über schweres
gerät schwerere waffen
und setzt seine angriffe mit dem du
greift die gesamte
bei der sitzung heute
sprach der ukrainische außenminister
probleme mit seinem kollegen und der
nato und in der eu
und wir alle sprachen ihm und seinen
tiefsten respekt für den mut ihrer und
den kampfgeist des ukrainischen volkes
aus seit vielen monaten haben ihr gewand
davor dass präsident putin die absicht
hatte die ukraine anzugreifen deshalb
haben die nato verbündeten sich
unermüdlich
angestrengt eine diplomatische lösung zu
finden und haben auch darauf hingewiesen
dass russland einen sehr hohen preis für
den erneuten angriff der ukraine
bezahlen würde russland zahlt diesen
preis bereits jetzt dies ist präsident
putins krieg ein krieg den er mutwillig
gewählt geplant hat gegen ein
friedliches land
stop wir appellieren an präsident putin
stoppen sie diesen krieg sofort bei
angry sie ihn sehen sie all ihre
streitkräfte
bedingungslos aus der ukraine an
und beginnen sie jetzt wieder
verbindlich mit diplomatischen
gesprächen die nato verbündeten haben
ihre unterstützung für die ukraine
aufgeschlossen zu unterstützen die
selbstverteidigungskräfte der keine laut
un charta heute haben die dringende
notwendigkeit in der krise weiter so zu
verfahren
bekräftigt auch im interesse der nato
alliierten sicherheit und zwar auf land
und
in der luft die verbündeten in den usa
kanada und in europa haben ihre präsenz
verstärkt die nato harrys pons fonds
haben wir zum ersten mal eingesetzt über
130 sind in alarmbereitschaft
und über 200 schiffe vor ort ist ins
mittelmeer sind in der nähe wir werden
jeden zentimeter nato territorium
verteidigen
die nato ist ein verteidigungsbündnis
unser ziel ist es unsere
mitgliedsnationen
in sicherheit sobald die sicherheit zu
schützen wir sind nicht unter 1 dieses
konfliktes wir haben ein hohes interesse
daran dafür zu sorgen dass der konflikt
sichtlich weiter ausdehnt über die
grenzen der jetzigen kriegerischen
handlungen weil das menschliche leid die
zerstörungen sonst unermesslich zunehmen
würden die nato will keinen krieg mit
russland
der ehrgeiz des kreml besteht darin eine
größere einflusssphäre
das ist der papst in der crew will wählt
die nato welt den pfad alle partner die
gefährdet sein können zu unterstützen
ich hab zu gehören auch georgien und
herz und bosnien herzegowina es geht uns
um die sicherheit unserer verbündeten
und der nachbarländer
wir setzen uns mit allen kräften dafür
ein wir haben
auch in zukunft
das bestreben konflikte friedlich
beizulegen es steht viel auf dem spiel
demokratie
oder
diktatorischer autokraten an der macht
in welcher welt wollen wir in zukunft
legen
die zeiten haben sich geändert auch für
die nato für viele jahre aber wir setzen
weiterhin auf
diplomatische verhandlungen in
konfliktfällen deren friedliche
beilegung
missverständnisse und viel kalkül
auszuschließen oder auszuräumen wir
können bereits jetzt lehren ziehen aus
diesem konflikt wenn wir in sicherheit
leben wollen und müssen wir alle in
strategischer solidarität zusammen
stehen die nato und die nachbarländer
kein land wird alleine irgendetwas
unternehmen
präsident putin hat es nicht geschafft
einen keil zwischen
treiben die nato stets zusammen ist
geeinter denn je und arbeiten noch enger
zusammen mit gleichgesinnten
der eu aber auch finnland und schweden
als reaktion auf die russische
aggression haben wir einen wurf
schlechten informationsaustausch und
eine engere zusammenarbeit mit finnland
und schweden vereinbart diese sind und
jetzt noch enger wird uns der nato
zusammenarbeiten
die eu-außenminister haben gemeinsam mit
uns getan und jetzt stehe ich für ihre
fragen bereit
james länder bbc können sie etwas mehr
sagen zu den optionen die sie ins auge
zu gast haben ländern wie bosnien und
georgien zu helfen sie zu unterstützen
und was haben die nato-verbündeten
diskutiert im bezug auf mögliche
verstärkte militärische unterstützung
der ukraine
und drittens haben sie weitere mögliche
schritte diskutiert
sieht unterstützung vor die nato
verbündeten für georgien christin
hercegovina und viele partner das machen
wir seit vielen ländern kapazitäts
bildung stärkung der
sicherheitsinstitutionen als schulungs
ausbildungsgänge in georgien gemeinsame
manöver übungen und auch mit anderen
drittländern und partner wir haben noch
keine endgültigen entscheidungen
getroffen aber wir sind uns
weitestgehend einig darin dass wir mehr
domes die dinge einem scale up zu
unterziehen
sicherheitseinrichtungen
institutionen zu stärken
verstärkte gemeinsame übungen und mehr
aktivitäten unterstützung all dieser
länder denn was wir gerade sehen erleben
in der ukraine ist ein großes risiko
es kann stehen für mehr intervention
subversives vorgehen
russische
infiltration
die nato
bieten der ukraine unterstützung ich
glaube wir müssen hier immer daran
denken
dass wir das seit vielen jahren tun wir
tun das jetzt in verstärktem verstärktem
maße verschiedener arten der
unterstützung des supports für die
ukraine das ist von entscheidender
wichtigkeit zu diesem zeitpunkt für die
ukraine dann das thema flugverbot
das wurde angesprochen aber die natur
verbindet sind der ansicht dass keine
nato flugzeuge fliegen sollten im
ukrainischen luftraum oder auch andere
voraus westlichen staaten das nicht tun
sollen
dafür dass der support der nato
etwas ändern kann der russische
vormarsch ging ja langsamer von statten
geht aber vorrang gibt es hier etwas das
ist die nato tun könnte damit die
schlacht in der ukraine
eine entscheidende änderung
erfährt
hat sich bei der natur die einstellung
vielleicht geändert zu welchem ergebnis
kam ihre heutige sitzung
also die
fahrlässigen gefährlichen aktionen rund
um das kraftwerk von christa letzten
acht haben gezeigt wie gefährlich so
etwas ist militärische tänze beschuss in
der nähe von atomkraftwerken
vergrößert die gefahr um ein vielfaches
umso wichtiger dass präsident putin den
krieg bald beendet
wir unterstützen die truppen in der ober
halte so quer das können in ihren
dramatischen junioren das war die
botschaft der minister heute der nato
der eu und wir haben das noch einmal
untermauert angesichts dieser
potenziellen gefahr beim kampf um
atomkraftwerke in putins erbarmungslosen
krieg
thema munition waffen rüstung das im
blick ihr seht dass präsident putin die
stärke der ukrainischen streitkräfte
total unterschätzt hat es gelang ihm
zurückzukämpfen den russischen vormarsch
zu verlangsamen
vor allem durch den großen hut und den
kampfgeist der ukrainischen streitkräfte
reste des mutes des kampfgeistes der
menschen in der ukraine und ihres
präsidenten zielinsky das hat die russen
verlangsamte bei ihrem vormarsch in die
nato verbündeten haben ja
viele schulungen durchgeführt seit
vielen jahren seit 2010 sehr unsere
ukrainischen streitkräfte in den usa
kanada großbritannien
brüssel und auch die türkei alle haben
ausrüster
auch militärische ausrüstung
geliefert und haben zehntausende
ukrainische soldaten
geschult trainiert die steht im moment
an den fronten und das war in chancen
für die stärke der ukrainischen
streitkräfte und wir stocken unsere
unterstützung und support noch einmal
auf der messe kleines klar erkennen im
vergleich zu dem wo die ukrainische
armee im jahr 2014 stand sind die
schulungs gänge unterstützt von
ausrüstung der nato-verbündeten seit
2014 dazu geführt hat dass die
kommandostrukturen verbessert wurden die
schulungen viel bewirkt haben die
ausrüstung besser ist so dass die
ukrainische armee viel stärker ist und
einige putts becks der russen erreichen
konnte
im anschluss daran noch eine frage herr
generalsekretär
sogar generell dittloff hat die meinung
vorgetragen dass die nato und die usa so
bald wie möglich
aus humanitären gründen auch was trinken
müssen im sinne der überflugrechte was
sagt sie zu dieser position wie lange
wird es dauern bis putin doch die
ukraine zerstört werden sie das zulassen
also das was im moment in der ukraine
stattfindet es ganz schrecklich
schmerzhaft wir sehen zerstörung
menschliches leid so wie wir es seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg in europa nicht mehr
gesehen haben der mut des ukrainischen
volkes ist enorm das sich gegen die
russische invasion stimmt aber gegen
putins
deshalb steigern wir auch unsere
unterstützung
deshalb haben die nato-verbündeten auch
die schärfsten sanktionen die es je
gegeben hat da hängt deshalb
mobilisieren wir unterstützung der
ganzen welt und appellieren immer wieder
an präsident putin diesen krieg
gleichzeitig sind wir verantwortlich als
nato verbündete sie sind regelung
daran zu hindern über die grenzen der
ukraine hinaus zu gehen weil das noch
verheerender noch gefährlicher wäre und
noch viel mehr menschliches leiden
bewerten wir haben
wir befinden uns noch sind heidi hinein